-This is very exciting.
You went on a global press tour
to promote
this season of the show.
-Yeah, well, you know,
Berlin, but, yes, global.
-Okay.
It's over ocean at least.
-Yeah.
-You were in Berlin.
I heard this was
very exciting for you.
You stayed in the hotel
where Michael Jackson
famously dangled his child.
-Dangled the baby.
Baby Blanket.
-Yeah, baby Blanket.
-You guys know Blanket, right?
I mean, one of the great --
one of the top 10 baby names.
-Yeah.
-You're a dad, so...
-Yeah, I was so upset
that Blanket was taken.
-I can only imagine.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I mean, as soon as
we got there,
you know, it's me,
the great Danielle Brooks,
who plays Taystee.
-She's fantastic.
-I mean, one of the greats.
The wonderful Jackie Cruz.
And so, we were there.
And I was the quirky
of the bunch, you know?
And so, right away,
as soon as we got there,
I said,
"Let me see this balcony."
[ Laughter ]
-You asked the hotel staff?
-Because they're very good
at being, like, polite,
reasonable human beings.
So it gives me the space I need
to just, right away,
move in with that,
which I did.
-I imagine the hotel has chosen
not to promote this as a thing.
-And I don't know why.
I don't know why.
[ Laughter ]
I got to be totally honest,
I actually have no idea
what the name of the hotel is.
I only know that it was
the baby Blanket hotel.
[ Laughter ]
And if I had to get back,
I would just, you know,
Google that, I guess.
Oh, wonderful hotel.
Such wonderful people.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you ever
get to the balcony?
-Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, big-time, big-time.
[ Laughter ]
We dangled so many things
off the balcony.
The whole --
The whole junket,
I couldn't focus
'cause I was just, like,
"Why aren't we doing
the whole thing on the balcony?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And, yes.
-I'm so glad
you're bringing attention back
to that historic moment.
-Yeah.
It's actually -- It's messed up.
Because, you know,
he passed away.
But his ghost
still haunts those halls.
-Really?
-Yes, it does.
-Oh, that's good to know.
-Yeah, yeah.
Big fan of the show.
Of "Orange is the New Black."
-Oh, got you.
Not this one.
-On Netflix, yes.
-Oh, so, in the haunting,
he gives you --
-He loves Netflix, Michael, yes.
-So, Michael Jackson's ghost
takes time out
to compliment your work.
-Oh, he's such a great guy.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
You know he has a great --
He has those little loafers
and the white socks,
which I love, and I do.
-That's interesting, 'cause
I never know, as a ghost,
do you still
have your old clothes?
-Oh, yeah. You have
your kind of hero life outfit,
but you would maybe a suit like
this when you become a ghost.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And so, for him, it's that.
And we talked about that,
'cause we have that in common.
-Now, he didn't die there.
Why'd he end up
back at that hotel?
[ Laughter ]
-Now that's the kind of quantum
science I don't get mixed up in.
-I apologize.
-I don't go there.
-Yeah, no.
Shame on me for asking.
-Yes, yes.